bueno
ah
[Música]
bienvenidos a en exclusivo de france 24
en la novena cumbre de las américas en
la ciudad de los ángeles y en el marco
de esta cumbre me abren espacios
haciendo al presidente de paraguay mario
abdo benítez presidente muchísimas
gracias por su tiempo para france 24
conjuntos notariales empiezo por
preguntarle usted encima de los
asistentes a esta cumbre de las américas
pero hay varias ausencias que
ensombrecen de alguna manera en
resultado el posible resultado de esta
cumbre he estado usted de acuerdo con la
exclusión de cuba de venezuela y de
nicaragua mire yo respeto la decisión
soberana del país anfitrión eeuu del
país anfitrión y respetamos ahora
paraguay tiene una posición muy firme en
defensa de la democracia
el no
tampoco quedarnos callados cuando vemos
que las democracias están amenazadas de
hecho paraguay rompió relaciones
con venezuela una vez culminado el
proceso último electoral de venezuela
como nosotros como integrantes del grupo
de lima
consideramos que el proceso electoral
fue ilegítimo
si nosotros consideramos que el proceso
electoral fue ilegítimo el resultado de
ese proceso electoral obviamente no
podemos convalidar
paraguay tuvo una posición creo que fue
el único país de la región que rompió
relaciones diplomáticas con venezuela
en el caso de nicaragua también hay más
de siete creo que ex candidatos a
presidentes de la república
fueron fueron detenidos con la justicia
tampoco nos vemos nosotros que nicaragua
tenga un
un comportamiento democrático por parte
de sus autoridades y nos preocupa
diciendo eso reitero nosotros respetamos
la decisión del país anfitrión que eeuu
de invitar a quienes consideren ellos el
propicio para esta cumbre más allá de la
exclusión a través de estos canales
diplomáticos entonces qué medidas se
pueden tomar concretamente para que sean
los ciudadanos de los respectivos países
los que tomen las decisiones y no estos
representantes que en su caso por
ejemplo no son reconocidos yo creo que
acá nosotros tenemos
enormes desafíos como
como región
uno de uno de esos desafíos es
consolidar la democracia proteger las
democracias y participar para custodiar
nuestras democracias hoy lo que en algún
foro internacional se puede proponer
sería un diálogo para que avancemos
hacia procesos electorales democráticos
y que democráticos y que estos países
recuperen su democracia a través de un
proceso eleccionario abierto
transparente donde se respete la
voluntad popular donde habla donde haya
garantías para que todas las fuerzas
políticas participen y bueno y ese es el
primer paso unas elecciones libres que
es un poco el sustento de la democracia
y segundo gobernar también bajo los
principios democráticos porque la
democracia
no culmina en un proceso electoral sino
que vivir en democracia es mucho más
amplio que solamente culminar un proceso
electoral respetar las instituciones
respetar las libertades públicas
respetar la libertad de prensa no
perseguir a los a los adversarios
políticos
subordinando las instituciones que
tienen que estar al ser y yo de la
sociedad y no del liderazgo de turno en
fin las democracias se van construyendo
diariamente y el proceso que por lo
menos yo veo que podemos nosotros desde
aquí proponer es un diálogo para
recuperar las democracias en estos
países donde hoy no vienen simplemente
no viven en democracia hay consenso
entre los países asistentes los que sí
asistieron asistieron y las
representaciones por ejemplo en el caso
de méxico para incluir esto en la
declaración final de la cumbre de las
américas
no sé si así como yo estoy diciendo
taxativamente pero si hay consenso sobre
la necesidad de proponer un diálogo
sobre la defensa de principios
democráticos
y yo creo que esto es muy saludable es
muy saludable que levantemos nuestra voz
pero que también como veremos para una
vía de solución para proponer un camino
de salida para que el mundo
para no construir barreras solamente
sino que empezar a construir puentes de
salida para estas esta situación que
están viviendo algunas algunas de las
sociedades demostradas de nuestra región
prefieren otro tema de esta cumbre es la
migración del problema migratorio cuáles
van a ser los argumentos de paraguay
para discutir esta materia y nosotros
estamos como todo el mundo muy
preocupado por la migración yo creo que
nunca la humanidad ha vivido
tanta vibración en todo el mundo desde
migrantes sirios hasta la mayor
migración que hemos visto en los últimos
tiempos que es la venezolana más de 5
millones de venezolanos vibrando por el
mundo gradas que requieren de asistencia
que requieren de gestos de solidaridad
paraguay por ejemplo
ha recibido ya muchos en nuestros casos
que son los migrantes que llegan a
nuestro país son los venezolanos hemos
facilitado inclusive con visas hemos
hecho acuerdos para que cotiza vencidas
con pasaportes vencidos puedan hacer su
documentación en nuestro país pero acá
lo importante es construir una
política general
primero atendiendo y viendo esta
problemática segundo también
construyendo recursos para aquellos
países que recepcionan a la mayor
cantidad de migrantes porque eso es
equilibra también un presupuesto general
de gastos a la nación y el resto tenemos
que ser solidarios con los países por
ejemplo colombia que está recibiendo es
uno de los países que reciben mayor
cantidad de migrantes los últimos años
eso requiere también de una solidaridad
internacional y ver un poco que podemos
hacer para garantizarle una vida digna a
aquellos que por diferentes razones ya
sean políticas económicas por
situaciones de guerra
son hoy víctimas de esta triste realidad
que es la gran migración en el mundo las
solicitudes entonces que eeuu se
invierta más en los países del sur del
continente para atender este problema de
la y claro y también atacar de fondo
porque la gente sale de los países uno
puede ser por situaciones de inequidad
por situaciones de falta de oportunidad
entonces y también tenemos que actuar
para generar oportunidades y ser
solidario para que se fortalezca la
economía y haya mayor equidad en la
región y que la gente no tenga que salir
de su país porque le falta oportunidades
eso es un área que hay que abordar
necesariamente la mayor presencia de
inversiones de asistencia de política
que que puedan contener la vibración
porque la gente pueda encontrar
oportunidades en sus países segundo la
situación política que también es un
tema que hay que abordar necesariamente
en algunos en algunos casos la situación
de conflictos como como los sirios que
son creo que hay más de 4 millones de
sirios por el mundo ahora la situación
que estamos viviendo este en ucrania los
migrantes de afganistán después de la
culminación del conflicto de la
presencia de esta unión a juanita
tuvieron una migración importante de más
de 2 millones de afganos que se salieron
de afganistán y están buscando un nuevo
lugar donde vivir los de esta era
entonces es una situación que amerita
que tomemos una decisión en conjunto
atendiendo toda esta problemática y
construir alternativa para las
diferentes problemáticas que tenemos
tiene que ser algo mucho más integral
que solamente medidas
por momentos coyunturales
y otro de los problemas que genera
también la migración es el crimen tras
la transnacional y por esto quería
también preguntarle por el asesinato en
colombia del fiscal marcelo pecci quien
dio la orden de asesinar al fiscal y eso
está en proceso de investigación lo que
sí
es un fue una gran tragedia para nuestro
país muestra como el crimen es lo que
mejor se ha globalizado en el mundo como
bien lo dijiste el crimen transnacional
y la lucha contra el crimen
transnacional también requiere de una
gran cooperación
de un trabajo en conjunto el lo que
ocurrió con page y fue muy doloroso para
nosotros
muy yo no recuerdo un caso de este tipo
en paraguay
no se lo asesino paraguay se lo asesinó
en cartagena en colombia agradezco la
colaboración del presidente del buque de
la fiscalía colombiana de la policía
para dar este primer paso porque todos
los autores materiales hoy ya están
fueron detenidos fueron identificados
retenidos y están a disposición hoy de
la justicia este es el primer paso pero
lo que nosotros realmente queremos es
poder responder tu pregunta a quien dio
la orden bueno y eso ya forma parte de
un proceso de investigación conjunta que
estamos haciendo entre colombia-paraguay
eeuu también está colaborando para
tratar de encontrar a los autores
morales de este crimen y que no quede
impune y que se entienda que hoy el
crimen organizado no respeta ninguna
frontera y nuestra estrategia también
tiene que ser una estrategia coordinada
entre los países aliados presidente
porque estaba el fiscal marcelo pecci
ximo un equipo de seguridad en colombia
bueno la información que tenemos es que
él no anuncio a las autoridades
colombianas de ese viaje
no pidió asistencia del en paraguay si
tiene todo un equipo de seguridad que lo
protege por los casos delicados que
llevaba al fiscal page pero la
información que tenemos no quiero
ahondar mucho en eso porque no conozco a
profundidad pero lo que tenemos voy a
que él no pidió asistencia de hecho creo
que ni nuestra embajada estaba en
conocimiento del viaje del fiscal
privado con los míos en el momento
entonces sé que él sale del país si no
solicita asistencia no hay no hay
dispositivo de seguridad para debería
haber pero me imagino que lo que
corresponde es que el informe y que
solicita asistencia yo no creo que
ningún gobierno le niegue asistencia a
un fiscal que tiene casos que le puedan
generar algún tipo de riesgo y que
requiera de protección para yo no creo
que haya ningún tipo de problema en este
caso lastimosamente
nadie sabía que el fiscal page y por lo
menos oficialmente e institucionalmente
no hubo una comunicación ni una
solicitud de seguridad al gobierno de
colom si no estoy seguro que lo hubiese
tenido presidente mayor abdo benítez
muchas gracias por su tiempo para
france24 muchas gracias y gracias a
ustedes por estar en sintonía de trans
104 sigan viendo toda la actualización
de la cumbre de las américas en france
24 y france 24 puntos